so we thought maybe Williamson start up
at this part of the panel a little bit
of splash ladies and gentlemen your
Aquaman
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh God
[Applause]
the king is here finally it makes sense
to your uncle makes sense a rocker
because everyone is super wet right now
[Applause]
this man I want you to know this man
came all the way from Australia last
night - oh I came all the way from
Australia for you guys I love you too
man congratulations and welcome to all
this I mean what is it what can you say
about our Korean what have you enjoyed
and what's been exciting for you your
buddy oh I've done that worthy for this
I feel very looks good on you man it's
been awesome
yeah maybe our kid get away anything
this fish yeah
I know man leave them alone this thank
you thanks for looking out for me so
what if it what have you enjoyed so far
being Aquaman yeah it's a livable I had
a great time in London
Justice League I love them what no I
wasn't stop making all my Trident yeah
it's just it I'm so stoked to show you
what we have today
eight 18 months away from Aquaman and
there's a lot of stuff you do want to
show you unfortunately I wish I could
take this and go and you guys can see
what I've seen but unfortunately we
can't show too much can't show too much
yeah we're a little ways away but we
made something really really special
yeah you were wearing with James Wan
absolutely use a little danger pad I
love them yeah we're having a great time
down there he wish you could be here
everyone does
amber Patrick everyone says hello Yaya
love my cast and we made a little
special things yeah James made a special
Memphis for you let's take a look
you